>> Bill: BILL MELUGIN STARTING
COVERAGE.
>> Dana: THE WHITE HOUSE IS
HITTING BACK AT TEXAS GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT IN RESPONSE TO
GOVERNOR'S PLAN TO PUT
IMMIGRANTS ON BUSES AND DRIVE
THEM TO THE U.S. CAPITOL.
>> I THINK IT'S CLEAR THIS IS A
PUBLICITY STUNT.
HIS OWN OFFICE ADMITS A MIGRANT
WOULD NEED TO BE VOLUNTARILY
TRANSPORTED.
THEY CAN'T FORCE THEM TO.
IT LIES WITH FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND NOT THE STATES.
I KNOW THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS OR
ANY STATE DOESN'T HAVE THE
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO COMPEL
ANYONE TO GET ON A BUS.
>> Dana: GOVERNOR ABBOTT
ANNOUNCED THE PLAN YESTERDAY IN
RESPONSE TO THE PRESIDENT'S
UNWILLINGNESS TO PROTECT THE
BORDER.
>> Bill: IMMIGRATION ISSUE
EXPECTED TO HAVE A BIG IMPACT
ON THE MID-TERMS.
KARL ROVE WITH ANALYSIS.
GOOD MORNING.
YOU HAVE A WHITE BOARD BUT HERE
IS THE LIST OF SENATORS, FIVE
OF THEM ARE DEMOCRATS, THAT
OPPOSE DROPPING TITLE 42.
CALL FOR NUMBER FIVE, GUYS, AS
BACK DROP HERE, KARL.
THIS WAS A HEADLINE FROM MARCH
20th.
FAUCI SAYS U.S. UNLIKELY TO SEE
SURGE FROM NEW COVID-19
VARIANT, ALL RIGHT?
THAT'S FROM MARCH 20th.
THIS HEADLINE YESTERDAY WHERE
WE ARE LIKELY TO SEE A SURGE IN
THE FALL.
SO FAUCI IS SEEING IT BOTH WAYS
OVER THE PAST THREE WEEKS.
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT HIS
POSITION IS.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS AND THE ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER.
I THINK TITLE 42 COULD COME
BACK AGAIN OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL WEEKS.
YOUR VIEW IS WHAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL YOU PUT YOUR
FINGER ON THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING.
THE PEOPLE ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE ARE UP FOR ELECTION THIS
YEAR THAT CAME OUT IN FAVOR.
VULNERABLE DEMOCRATS.
THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL ON THE
HANDLING OF IMMIGRATION LAST
YEAR IN MARCH OF LAST YEAR WAS
40%.
TODAY IT IS 32%.
AND IF WE SEE 18,000 PEOPLE A
DAY COMING ACROSS THE BORDER,
THEN WE ARE GOING TO SEE THOSE
NUMBERS SINK EVEN LOWER.
I LOVE THAT JEN PSAKI SAID IT
IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENFORCE THE
IMMIGRATION LAWS, NOT THE STATE.
THEREFORE HE CAN'T DO IT.
WHEN IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GOING TO START ENFORCING THE
LAW.
THE STATE OF TEXAS IS SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY WEEK
IN ORDER TO FILL THE GAPS ON
THE BORDER THAT THE BORDER
PATROL OPENLY SAYS WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES,
TECHNOLOGY AND PEOPLE TO MAN.
I SPENT THE LAST WEEKEND WITH
THE FATHER OF ONE OF THE
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN DEPLOYED TO
THE BORDER.
HIS SON IS TELLING THEM EVERY
NIGHT HIS SQUAD IS OUT ALL
NIGHT LONG WITH NIGHT VISION
GOGGLES AND HEAVILY ARMED AND
THEY TAKE FIRE FROM ACROSS THE
RIVER.
THE MEXICAN CARTELS SHOOT
TRACERS TO MAKE CERTAIN THEIR
APPEARANCE IS KNOWN AND EVERY
NIGHT THEY PICK UP DOZENS OF
ILLEGALS IN ONE VERY SMALL
STRETCH, MAYBE A COUPLE OF
MILES LONG ON THE BORDER.
AND OUR BORDER WITH MEXICO IS
HUNDREDS OF MILES LONG.
SO THIS IS A GRAVE CRISIS FOR
THE COUNTRY.
THE NONCHALANT ATTITUDE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE JEN PSAKI AS SHE
LEAVES FOR CABLE TV NEWS IS
WE'RE IN CHARGE, DON'T WORRY
ABOUT IT, WE HAVE IT HANDLED.
THEY DON'T.
IT WILL COME BACK TO BITE THEM
BIG TIME IN THE ELECTION.
>> Dana: POLITICAL CALCULATION.
THE WHITE HOUSE CAN COUNT AND
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THEIR
POLL NUMBERS ON THIS BUT THEY
SEEM TO BE MAKING A DIFFERENT
CALCULATION.
I KNOW THAT THE LEFT WING
IMMIGRATION GROUPS THAT REALLY
WANTED TITLE 42 TO BE LIFTED
THEY MUST BE VERY PERSUASIVE.
WHEN THE PRIME MINISTER AS I
CALL HIM RON KLAIN CHIEF OF
STAFF, AS THEY LOOK AT THIS
MAYBE THEY THINK ONE, LIFTING
IT IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO ON
THE MERITS.
BUT SOMETHING TELLS ME
PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE DONE THIS IN
HIS PREVIOUS POSITION AS A
SENATOR.
HE MIGHT HAVE BEEN ONE OF THOSE
THAT HAD BEEN A CO-SPONSOR TO
KEEP IT.
>> YEAH, THAT'S VERY
INTERESTING INSIGHT.
VERY KEY ONE.
REMEMBER, WHAT THE PROGRESSIVES
ARE SAYING IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATORS IN THE SENATE THE
REASON YOUR NUMBERS ARE LOW YOU
AREN'T DOING ENOUGH IN PURSUIT
OF PROGRESSIVE GOALS.
YOU HAVE TITLE 42 STILL IN
PLACE.
YOU'LL GET BETTER -- PASS BUILD
BACK BETTER AND PUT THE 71
EXECUTIVE ORDERS INCLUDING THE
ENDING OF TITLE 42 PROHIBITIONS
AT THE BORDER AND DEMOCRATS
WILL GAIN SEATS IN THE CONGRESS.
SO THE MINDSET OF THE
PROGRESSIVES IS YOU'VE GOT TO
DO THESE WEIRD THINGS LIKE GET
RID OF TITLE 42 AND END STUDENT
DEBT AND MAKE THE OTHER CHANGES
WE CAN'T GET PASSED THROUGH LAW
IN EXECUTIVE ORDER AND CAUSE
DEMOCRAT ENTHUSIASM TO RISE AND
WE'LL HAVE A GOOD ELECTION IN
THE FALL.
THAT'S NUTTY AND SO DO SENATORS
IN PLACES LIKE NEW HAMPSHIRE
AND ARIZONA AND ELSEWHERE WHO
ARE IN HOTLY CONTESTED RACES.
>> Bill: REMEMBER CDC WE'LL GO
ON THEIR GUIDANCE A WEEK AGO.
FAUCI HAS HAD DOUBLE SPEAK IN
THREE WEEKS.
IN 21 DAYS YOU'VE SEEN BOTH
SIDES OF THESE ISSUES COMING UP
IN TH